that high-profile trial last summer it
lasted three weeks
and in it johnny depp said well i was
libelled uh
that the sons article that had been
printed in 2018 had
accused him of being a wife beater and
in that case they heard about
14 assaults that were said to have taken
place now in november
the judge said well that he believed
they were substantially true certainly
12 out of 14 of them on the balance of
probabilities and as a result johnny
depp
lost his libel case and it was at that
point that his legal team
said that the decision was as perverse
as it was bewildering that they would be
appealing so that's where we are today
uh here at the royal courts of justice
where they were seeking permission
to appeal and the first thing that the
legal team reports putting forward is
that they have
fresh evidence and it relates to a
donation
of seven million dollars that was said
to have been made by
the actor's wife at the time amber heard
uh as part of her divorce settlement
now it was said in the judgment that
this meant that there was no way amber
heard could be seen as a gold digger
but what andrew caldecott qc argued in
court today is that
amber heard had told a calculated
and manipulative lie that in fact she'd
only given a hundred thousand dollars to
one charity 450
000 to another and that the donation was
designed to send a potent
subliminal message that i want him to
pay but i don't want to keep a dime of
it
because of the way i've been treated and
that that in itself
tipped the scales against uh mr depp
at the very beginning now the team for
the sun
the legal team for the sun today said
well number one
this isn't fresh evidence that they
could have put the effort in beforehand
to have had it available at the original
trial
and that either way saying that you're
going to donate seven million dollars
doesn't mean to say that you've paid it
already and that actually
amber heard intended to still pay that
money another
thing that came up today was about a
tape recording now this
we'd heard about in the trial and in
that tape recording both of them can be
heard
but amber heard said she can't promise
she won't get physical again
now what johnny depp's team have argued
in court today is not enough weight was
given
to these tapes to evidence that she too
had been violent
and that the judge did not conduct a
judicial fact-finding
exercise correctly well the sun's team
sons team in defense said well
it doesn't mean she wasn't a victim of
serious domestic violence whatever may
have happened
during that relationship so plenty to be
said
on both sides the judgment
the decision about whether they will be
able to appeal has been reserved so
we'll get that
at a later date